all right so I in the attraction I'm I'm
here at Stanford now and I have been a
here for three for two for two years and
I work on cyber policy and and and I
work on cyber policy and security issues
here at Stanford and and do a lot of
work with policy makers and so on on
cybersecurity I spent 25 years in
Washington before that 29 years in
Washington before that working I key
policy issues and and before that I was
a congressional staff member a staff
scientist for for a congressional
committee so I have some familiarity
with the way in which the the the system
works the the story that was just told
of about technology and so on and and
putting criminality near in your pockets
as some years ago I came across a
wonderful saying to the effect that
there are three roads to ruin sex is the
most fun alcohol is the fastest and
technology is the most certain and and
and I have come to believe that and over
the years I I have become a late adopter
of technology for exactly that reason
let somebody else be on the bleeding
edge so we were I'm here to talk because
a last minute speaker cancelled and and
that's fine I was you so you're the
you're the first audience that I've
given this talk to the the Presidential
Commission released a report that report
last Friday in fact publicly it was
given to the president on on Thursday
the the day before and this is the
result of seven months of deliberation
on what you will see is a very broad
charge okay
the Commission will make detailed
recommendations strengthen secure sever
security in both the public and private
sectors while protecting privacy
ensuring safety Public Safety national
economic security fostering the
discovery and development new technical
solutions and bolstering partnerships
between federal state local governments
in the private sector and the
development motion and use of technology
cyber security technologies best
practices and policies okay that's a
mouthful it's a very broad charge right
and we had seven months to produce a
report on this we we had the the the
report is available online at that
website if you just type in into a
Google search cyber security Commission
report the URL pops up of most price of
us on the Committee on the Commission is
that it's posted on the White House site
not just not just in this site which is
the which was the group that organized
this is the site that was established to
manage it you know manage the whole
process there they had a variety of
public meetings and and and and so on
and it was charged by executive order to
to to be to be created the broad context
for the Commission here is that in
February of 2013 so about three years
three and a half years ago
the Obama administration issued an
executive order a presidential order on
improving critical infrastructure of
cyber security that is critical
infrastructure is supposed to be that
[Music]
infrastructure largely in the private
sector that is critical for national
operations so in that for national
activity so it's things like a banking
system the electric grid and and and and
so on well that's an interesting
question the answer is no it except
insofar as state and local governments
were including we're in fact included in
that and as you may know elections are a
the electoral machinery is a part of
state and local
governments we I will talk about that
later and if you want to talk about that
more during the discussion I'm happy to
do that this led to the something called
in this cybersecurity framework now NIST
which is the National Institute for
Standards and Technology had a had
responsibility for creating this
framework so a voluntary framework for
critical infrastructure organizations to
manage their cybersecurity it was
intended to give people a give give
agencies and entities within the private
sector that think about cybersecurity
that provide critical infrastructure
services to think about cybersecurity a
language to talk about their
cybersecurity efforts and how they've
made progress and and so on and it was
meant to be entirely voluntary the three
years later the administration announced
its national cybersecurity action plan
and created the Commission this is the
commission that that I sat on and it was
drawn from you know from business and
former government and the in academia
and we were tasked to create the
recommendations as we described as I
described earlier and the idea was that
concrete recommendations to improve
cybersecurity over the next decade that
was the that was the intent okay what
can the US government do honest meant to
provide a roadmap for the next president
throughout most of the process we didn't
know who the next president was going to
be and we were really quite scrupulous
in not identifying Republicans or
Democrats that the Vice the the chair of
the Commission is known to be a Democrat
the vice chair of the Commission is
known to be a Republican but beyond that
you could not tell by listening to the
to the to the people around the table
who was our and who was D okay this was
a list of the the commissioners
Donnellan was a former national security
adviser to the president
obviously and some Palmisano former CEO
of IBM Vice Chair known to be Rojo
Republican but as they say everyone else
their political affiliation is unknown
and that was not a consideration in
either their selection or in fact in any
of the the discussion they'll tell you
quite candidly that there were really no
ideological discussions among the the
commissioners because all very pragmatic
we all had ideologies but it was all
very pragmatic so you know ranging from
keith alexander to was a former NSA
director president of mastercard you
know president of the chancellor of the
university of pittsburgh system former
in this director a wide variety of
players so yeah policy expertise i would
say yes there was significant there was
significant technical expertise on the
committee on the on the commission but
in ancient and interesting you should
bring that you should see that up in the
discussion in the in the discussion
question so the question there is how
much technical expertise do you actually
need to know in order to make good
policy well that i I reckon I recognize
that view okay and and and and we let's
know let's let's have that let's have
that discussion okay III would I have a
view that says it it's not as much as
you think okay and we can we can talk
about that all right so that's us okay
I'm not in there but that's that that
that's us here's something that we did
not here's what we didn't do okay and
this is important okay we
focused on the digital economy and if
you look at the text of the executive
order it really emphasizes things that
are related to the economy not
encryption not active defense at hacked
back not the role of offensive sovery
operations in in national policy not
cyber operations a part of the defense
strategy not Internet Governance a
variety of things we didn't do okay all
those are important all of those are
adjacent to the space of Internet sorry
of the digital economy but they're not
centrally to focus and believe me the
the internet economy the the digital
economy is a is big enough by itself
okay so we we circumscribed put what we
did we try to identify foundational
principles now these are principles you
they're not principles in the sense that
a physicist or an engineer with what
would would characterize them right
these are sort of sort of premises that
we go into it with if it in a sense I
mean they're the these are principles
that shaped our our thinking so let me
let me let me let me say some things
okay so the first and I'll spend a fair
amount of time on this slide here the
first of my timing I disco is for what
an hour an hour and fifty minutes okay
fine
including okay fine there's a
convergence between cyber and and
physical systems as we see with with IOT
that you know the we had on October 21st
we had a massive DDoS attack that
brought down many commercial important
commercial websites
and was unable to you know you know
brought brought it down and it was
traced back to a botnet you know is
living in IOT devices so that was an
interest that was interesting it was an
object lesson that the IOT and physic
and and what we normally regard as plain
old information technology are coming
together okay we think we we had the
premise I mean it was a National
Commission established by the President
of the United States okay so not
surprisingly we had a very us centric
view of what we should be doing we think
that the US has an important role as a
standard bearer for for cyber security
because we have this role in global
innovation the feds has ultimate
responsibility for the nation's defense
and security we don't privatize the ICBM
force nuclear submarines okay and there
are some threats against which the
United States really needs a government
to respond to and you can argue about
where that line is in cyberspace and we
did a lot of that argument and we
recognize that that's an argument but
the in the end the alt the ultimate
responsibility does live with the
federal government for certain levels of
threats that are very very large we can
argue about where that line is thanks at
the same time private sector is really
important right because the private
sector has a lot of expertise and a lot
of infrastructure and a lot of incentive
to protect right to defend and they own
and operate a lot of stuff and you can't
just pass a law telling them what to do
that's a very difficult thing if you
don't live in a command-and-control
economy and so you have to so you have
to find ways of persuading people to
cooperate with you structuring
incentives I mean so the language there
is incentives its persuasion it's
appealing to self-interest those kinds
of phrases
not you know you must do X now that's
the regulation side of the house and in
fact we did not completely avoid the
issue of regulation we did not say never
regulation question is when and where
and we'll talk about that later two
responsibilities within responsibility
Authority capability accountability
within every enterprises risk management
strategies they have to be aligned with
each other with and this is true in the
government as well so just as one
example of how you don't get alignment
okay you may wonder and we spend a fair
amount of time in there working on this
you may wonder why the federal
government is so screwed up when it
comes to information technology that's
not a bad question to ask as taxpayers
some of you are textures most of you are
probably taxpayers in in here US
citizens and and and and so on oh why is
your government unable to deal with
information technologies successfully
well one reason is that it doesn't a
government department that buys
information technology doesn't get to
set its own budget right it gets set by
the Congress every year and there are
winds that the Congress implements or
doesn't implement and and so on and the
idea of a stable budget is completely
foreign to the way in which government
agencies operate right so if you any of
you who have ever worked in private
industry you know the idea of investing
now to save money in the future you
understand that idea what doesn't happen
in government right this there there's
no idea that will save money in the
future okay it'll help our but you know
Congress will take it away and give it
to somebody else so they're the that's
an example of how incentives are
misaligned in the private sector another
example of how incentives are misaligned
okay we always hear about
how it's so important to put
cybersecurity build cybersecurity into
the design of a product from the
beginning right we always hear that
again and again it can't just be an
afterthought in the end why is it there
always why is it always an afterthought
it's an interesting question do you
think about the economics of it all if
you're trying to get a product out to
service which is going to be faster
getting a product that's out that will
you just pay attention on the
functionality of the product or you pay
function attention to the product and
security
they're gonna be harder to do two tasks
rather than one okay the answer is it's
gonna be harder to do two tasks and so
the guy who gets it out without security
has a market advantage and he gets two
we can argue if you don't believe that
well we can argue about that okay you
may say that that shouldn't be the case
but you I don't I don't I don't believe
that for a minute and we can that week
we can talk about that but okay so we
will talk about that all right we
believe that the cyber security problem
had to be pushed away from the end users
right how many times have you found that
you had to make a personal security
decision right do you accept the fact
that this website has you know the
certificate isn't quite valid right and
you know do you click through and sort
of the default behavior is yes okay
right you know do you check that you
really check the certificate II you
really want to view this you know all
those sorts of questions okay
no okay so we want to push the security
away from the end-user how far that's it
that's another question but that's the
philosophy of it you should configure
technologies and products in such a way
that's easy to do the right thing a hard
to do dangerous things that seems like
an obvious thing but it's
you know honored board the breach than
anyone anywhere else
I already addressed the question about
privacy security trust be primary
considerations rather than doing it at
the end we'll have the argument later
small and medium-sized enterprises the
SMA are essential stakeholders one of
the things that the government has done
is to focus a lot of attention I think
until now on the big guys on really big
entities not a bad place to start but
where our conclusion here is is that the
small and medium enterprises need a lot
of help the big firms they already have
the help they they they're swimming in
cybersecurity expertise and we can talk
about that about the level of technical
expertise that we want yes okay that's
right
when we talk about incentives a lot in
the report I think the answer to that is
yes the safety and reliability and so
this it was a central focus of our of
our of our work which was that we want
to emphasize incentives and heavy and
reliance on market forces to whenever
possible to enhance cybersecurity we
don't like regulation okay we really
don't like it doesn't mean we'll never
do it but we don't like it yes and we
can and yes and how can you how can you
so the question that comes from the back
of the the room is how we've been doing
regularly trying to avoid regulation for
for a very long time and this is where
you where we wound up okay and there's a
not very satisfactory situation and and
so on I think our answer to that has
been that nobody has created the
incentives for that and so the the
incentives have not been has not been a
successful approach the fact that some
incent some set of incentives hasn't
worked isn't a damning call to say that
all of them well will will be
ineffective that's the argument a direct
solution whereas in our field we saw
profs iteratively and it is rare and
that a solution works the first time
that we put security in the original
network control program for the art
Vanetta that ARPANET probably would not
have succeeded just because we would
have been bogged down early security
aspects so that's a little so when
that's the end of this conversation the
question is that's right and so in that
conversation and I'll just sit back okay
so that that's that's so there you go
that's correct okay I come down on that
side but yeah Silicon Valley is becoming
deathly afraid that they won't have a
market for their products even in
domestically or specially foreign
because there's no way to verify that
security services don't have massive
access to their data centers yes those
yes I agree but that is that that is a
debt is definitely a concern and that's
on the table starting yes I understand
and you'll note that that's one of the
issues that is a different issue of the
increase rate of the encryption issue
and we didn't talk about that so for for
reasons that you can you can imagine so
you're right
it is it is definitely a concern and we
can have a discussion afterwards on that
where I can tell you my own personal
views about it but not represent the
views of the Commission well you
organize the report around what we call
six imperatives okay under which were
groups multiple recommendations and
multiple multiple action items okay so
the first imperative was to say
secur today's internet and internet
information technology infrastructure
right so start secure do a better job of
securing what you have okay and this is
what do you have now how can you make it
better okay rather than inventing
something that's still better than that
so among the so among the things that we
talked about in there were the the idea
that we have to the first thing listed
here is that we have to increase the
robustness of the net against denial of
service spoofing and and and and and the
like and and other attacks on users that
sort of use the the basic structure and
connectivity of the net to complicate
your life the the second was a an effort
to defend and secure what we called the
converged IT infrastructure this is both
the cyber physical devices and the plain
old cyber devices that there was even
discussion of the question does the
meaning of critical is there no longer
such a thing as critical infrastructure
is everything critical now and you know
so that that's an interesting question
one of the observations that was made
during the the course of this our
deliberations was that if you look at
the DHS definition of critical
infrastructure it actually encompasses a
very large fraction of the US economy so
you remember the attack on Sony a couple
of years ago so it turns out that Sony
counts as Sony Pictures Entertainment
counts as critical infrastructure okay
yes it really does it is in the official
definition because it's part of the
infinite business sector would anybody
disagree with that no it's clearly part
of the entertainment sector the
entertainment sector there are the
entertainment companies are part of the
commercial sector and you will find
commercial sector listed under one of 16
sectors of critical infrastructure now
doesn't make any sense
that's an interesting question
okay in the old construct it didn't
maybe in the new world it does because
maybe Sony Pictures and through
entertainment computers are going to be
the source of interesting malware that
that goes out and gives the rest of the
world problems okay so we don't know we
the point is that there's this
convergence some aspects of that the
this is a something that a lot of people
care a lot about many attempts to deal
with this and will continue along those
lines
about improving information exchange one
of the issues with information exchange
is is that you you've got to get I mean
today information exchange is often by
fax okay and there's no good you you
can't really exchange information and
machine readable actionable way then the
other aspect of it is is taking action
based on on information that you get
that's hard to so that the entire
information in exchange infrastructure
needs to be enhanced
we also worried a lot about things like
security of GPS and various wireless
networks and and so on that you know how
critical GPS is just as one just as one
example
GPS matters even if you're not moving
right because it's because timing issues
the you know it's the source of a common
reference clock that's right
and the you know the fact that there's a
global clock that people use is a big
deal okay
we thought a lot about the question of
strong authentication we our goal we
have an aspirational goal that we'll be
able to eliminate passwords by 2020 no
no that's not really we you know if you
would ask me are we gonna and I got a
bet on that the answer is no but that's
not a bad aspirational goal that you
want to have really strong
authentication be the basis of access to
parts parts of the of the net and online
services and so on that you need it for
yeah
should we do so our emphasis on
authentication and focus more on
authorization and that is the main
objection I have to the best practices
that NIST is putting out say more so one
of the things about authentication is it
I need him to do the task for me
he doesn't have permission that you're
relying on authentication if you're
relying on authorization you authorize
me I can authorize him he can act on my
behalf
that is a fundamental failure in the
root cause of many of our problems
okay fair enough we can have more
discussion about that later too no no
inquisitive disagreement from from from
me here except this to say that we we
make the observation that lots of
problems come about because of
compromise user credentials today you
can reduce that the other the other
aspect of it was that we wanted to have
the US government be one just one but
one source of authoritative credentials
for validating digital identities okay
not the only one we the idea that the
government would be your gatekeeper to
to online services was not a popular one
among us but so that's right for
different purposes that's right
absolutely and so right so it's not it's
not one identity I mean we were very
conscious here over the need to avoid
the national ID card phenomena right you
you don't want your authentication
credential to be the equivalent of a
national ID card okay I mean that that
has all kinds of privacy implications we
didn't want to go down that path so I'm
sympathetic to
but there's a related problem if Google
takes away my gmail unlost
they took away my Google account I am
lost so there is an issue here of the
whole be of the sources of the
credentials and have enormous power over
us and that seems to be a a flaw and the
thinking of what's going on and I don't
see that that was addressed here it was
addressed to the extent that we said
that there there should be multiple
sources ok the Chrome browser to get it
our debate so it has to work with
industry to actually get into that
implementing this would in fact call for
something like that if you wanted to be
able to yes if you wanted to it if you
wanted to enable an individual to use
these you know US government authorized
credential to file an income tax return
for example which would not be a bad
idea you know wouldn't want it for every
time to do a trained pro 4 file he had
tax returns on you know not a bad thing
yeah it would have to be something like
that we thought that the new
cybersecurity framework was a good thing
that helped a lot of players get get
involved in a way with in a way with
cybersecurity that they weren't able to
before that it gives them a language of
way of planning a process you know
processes in ways of understanding the
the extent the nature of the risk that
they face in cyberspace we we said that
US government agency should be using the
framework notice that this is we the
framework was originally created to deal
with critical infrastructure we thought
it had broader applicability than that
we thought that regularly existing
regulations on cybersecurity of which
there are many should be aligned with
the framework we want the framework to
be a common language that's sort of the
a franca of cybersecurity and we wanted
luck to have liability protection of
some sort liability you know limits on
liability and so on parties that adopt a
framer now in saying that that's
actually there there's actually some
code in that statement okay which is
that it's a statement that there will be
liability for cybersecurity breaches
okay we actually think that the that
that that that's coming that's
inevitable and you may know that the
these the the IT industry has
successfully avoided liability for for
cybersecurity problems for a very long
time we don't think that's sustainable
that's just a prediction that's not that
that's not a recommendation and so on
that's just a prediction and so we're
saying that to the extent that you have
liability you the defenses against
liability involved things like best
practices and so on one of the best
practice would be to to use the
framework support we talked about
supporting small and business small and
medium-sized enterprises and business in
the use of the framework as well there's
a second the second imperative had to do
with securing tomorrow's digital economy
and here the IOT comes in with with with
full force
we talked about finding ways to improve
IOT security and and this is one of the
the things where I would argue I would
take very strong issue with the the
claim made that if you do cyber security
right you're advantaged rather than
disadvantage IOT devices right now are
have really crappy security built into
them you know common default passwords a
you know it's common and and and so on
and how you get to secure them how you
have to secure the missus is a problem
and there are all kinds of reasons why
you don't put them in from the beginning
when you're trying to grab market share
there are existing regulatory agencies
that do regulate cybersecurity sorry
that do regulate industries and
cybersecurity should be a part of that
assessment process so for example if
your regulatory authority that cares
about the reliability of the election
grid which there are some of you should
also be looking at cybersecurity for the
electric grid and there is existing
regulatory authority where they can
where they can do those things and we
thought that we should look at see what
the law would allow for liability for a
security liability for IOT devices we
thought that there should be R in the
focus of Rd on the development of usable
and affordable inherently secure systems
ok so every word in there is action was
actually negotiated okay that usable
security right
the idea that security functionality
should be useful it's a really big deal
right that you don't want people to
bypass the security because it's too
inconvenient to use affordable okay the
cost of developing really secure
software really reliable software really
in the language that I know of for
avionics the cost of avionics software
is something like 10 to a hundred times
this cost of ordinary software ok it's a
lot more secure it's a lot more reliable
by me fewer bugs in it but it's not
really affordable for general purpose
use the inherently secure part this is
the it's designed from the ground up
resilient and recoverable ok the guy the
bad guy will get in and so how do you
configure your system in a way that
enables you to recover from a
penetration quickly and with minimal
damage
lots of human factors in this lots of
non-technical factors in it so that's a
big deal in this too we thought that
there was a a a role for preparing
consumers to live in this age consumers
do not know how to manage service here
we heard the story earlier about
individuals not being able to manage
cybersecurity properly and that's very
true I confess in many cases I'm unable
to manage cybersecurity very well either
I'm one of the people who also clicks
through on the personal security
decisions about a certificate let's say
so we want them to be more informed so
one idea that we heard about that we
really liked was the idea of a nutrition
label on a on a product which would tell
you what goes into it ok so this was an
idea that was brought to us by Mudge
zaiko who used to work at DARPA he's
actually been asked by the US government
to set up a firm to do this kind of not
rating of security but to say this is
what goes into it and there will be some
listing of components in it and you can
make your assessment as to whether or
not those components are secure it'll
provide you at least with more
information that you have now how you
translate that into something usable by
the consumer that's an exercise for the
reader right that's that's something for
the future we want to we want to
consumer awareness campaign we want a
consumer Bill of Rights to say what
should consumers be expected to be a
reasonable expectation for them to have
what should they be able to SPECT in the
way of cybersecurity and what are their
responsibilities what do they have to do
in order to be secure and there's a
support for a usable Rd that is a user
orientation we talked about cyber cyber
security workforce capabilities that
there's certainly a role for educating
specialists people who do server
security full-time no question about
that but
we don't think that everybody who
touches cybersecurity has to be an
expert everybody is it has to know
something about cybersecurity in
particular we're thinking here that
middle managers and so on there's lots
of non practitioners often also ought to
know something about cybersecurity
that's hard I'm actually right now
working on a project to look at what
cybersecurity knowledge I can give in a
useful way to senior policy makers like
congressman and their staffs Congress
people in their staffs I certainly am
NOT going to be able to get them to the
alot level and they're not gonna do it
how can I what's the what what's the
minimum that I can give that will help
them make at least marginally more
sensible decisions it's an interesting
question there are things that change
constantly and there are things that
have fundamental principles that remain
the same so that and the figuring out
the right mix of that is is admittedly
difficult okay so we also said that you
have to pay attention to cybersecurity
in k-12 that's an interesting argument
and point of view and I think that's
right how we get it into an already
crowded curriculum that's gonna be an
interesting question but we put down our
marker and we also thought about the
idea of technological innovation that
can reduce the need for cyber full-time
specialists okay so these are the guys
who for example want to write programs
that will do automatic patch generation
it could be an interesting thing to do
that could help there was once upon a
time when you thought that if the volume
of long-distance phone calls was going
to go up every person in the country
that would have to be a telephone system
operator okay well guess what we are
right but it's peaking but the reason we
can do it now is because technology has
moved along and the question is is there
is there an analogous situation here
with cybersecurity improving the
cybersecurity of the US government this
is a big deal
one idea here was the
point out that the US government is
really like a bunch of small and medium
businesses put together under one roof
it's not this monolithic entity agency a
an agency B have completely different IT
needs so we thought that rather than
having each of them every agency yet
just struggle with basic issues about
connectivity to the Internet and so we
should all consolidated in one place and
the government should buy it all from
one from one agency within the US
government you may think that's a minor
thing that's a big deal in the US
government we thought about I mentioned
multi-year budgeting we really thought
that multi-year budgeting would really
help okay for reasons that should be
obvious we thought that they should move
to a risk management approach rather
than unjust and punter checklist of
requirements the difference is that if
it's just a checklist of requirements
cybersecurity is becomes completely
divorced from the actual mission of the
agency or ism to focus on risk
management you can see how your cyber
security posture affects how you can
execute your mission oh let's see
and we thought that the way in which the
US government itself is organized at the
top mattered we thought that there
should be an assistant to the president
for cybersecurity just comparable to the
assistant where the president for
counterterrorism that is very senior in
the in the White House
Cyprus acute we thought that there
should be a new cybersecurity strategy
in in the first six months should be a
new agency or repurposed old agency with
impression within DHS perhaps somewhere
else
we were silent on that part to handle
operational cybersecurity within the US
government exclusively States to let
the National Guard this was this was a
big deal too because the National Guard
has a lot of civilians in it who stay
current with technology and their day
jobs how can we bring them in how can we
use them effectively and States can can
use them in particular in ways that the
federal government can the last one was
focusing on international issues
international issues in the economy we
thought that there should be an emphasis
on developing common standards and an
assessment activities there's a bunch of
harmonization that needs to be done this
is the the term of art that says that
our laws ought to be consistent with the
laws in another country for example if
you want to do extradition for certain
computer crimes and and so on
you want the there there be similar laws
there is here and we wanted to promote
peacetime norms of responsible behavior
on cybersecurity through a variety of
ways the M lat process there has to do
with the multi it's the mutual legal
assistance treaties this is how a nation
a communicates with nation B in an
extradition request for example and and
how there are policy dimensions to that
and technical information exchange
dimensions to that on we thought that
those should be improved yeah the new UK
investigatory powers that's a very good
question and nobody knows the answer to
that nonetheless the question of
harmonization is an important question
okay if you're if you're going to
maintain relations outside and there are
many people who have different views of
what the most likely path for this is
okay are we looking at a uniform more
unified world or more balkanized world
and that's a very interesting question
the the the committee the Commission did
not address that point I have my own
views on it which I can talk about later
but that's I'm getting to the nearly
here and there in detail I promise
so really so these are some salient
points that I think that our personal
observations that are implied but not
explicitly stated in their horn I think
that the report really says that the
market has failed to produce the
cybersecurity that we need okay that you
can decide how you want to respond to
that market failure but there really the
market the market is fail to give us
what we what we want or we say that non
technical issues are as important as
technology that's really an important
statement I think that when you as soon
as you start talking incentives you're
talking about you're talking about
economics psychology organization policy
law and those are things are that are
that are very important we don't rule
out regulation it's the last resort
incentives are the thing they are
whether we want to go right now but
there is the in the background there is
a potential for regulation impossible
for possibility for regulation I
mentioned this earlier liability for
security breaches is going to come don't
know where don't know how don't know
when but it's gonna come and maybe
policymakers ought to step out in front
of that there's no silver bullet you
recognize that phrase from a variety of
other works no silver bullet here and
that's why our recommendations cover
such a broad waterfront I've seen many
press articles about this it emphasizes
some reports emphasizes a some reports
to emphasize B and so on and so forth
the reason is there's not one single
individual recommendation that stands
out the problem is we think that all of
them are necessary and there are no
silver bullets here famously recommended
said that she was gonna have a Manhattan
Project for cybersecurity didn't
consider that possibility nobody under
some discussion of that and we concluded
that with nobody understood what it
meant
there you go the last thing about the
about this is of course what you then
this obviously wasn't part of a report
what is the Trump administration gonna
do damned if I know okay
I do know that during the campaign both
Clinton and Trump agreed that
cybersecurity was really an important
issue that that was clear Trump has said
I want to do more offensive actions in
cyberspace you got a punch as well as
block in cyberspace and we may see that
who knows my personal research
specialization here at Stanford when I
when I write and so on it often deals
with the use of offensive operations in
cyberspace as instruments of national
policy that doesn't mean I think they're
always a good idea but we but what I do
is I I examine the implications of using
them and in that way if you want more
information about any of this stuff you
can contact me here and I am
particularly engaged interested in
engaging with tech-savvy people who have
any policy interests here so with that
let's open it up for discussion and
argument and these questions that you
disagree with me on let's start back
there for the trans-pacific partnership
to get up and running to negotiate why
now than eventually probably die
how does geographic scope and the speed
at which treaty negotiations take place
deal with the speed of technical
developments I mean BGP as protocol
doesn't have any concept of national
orders although even though the
agreements between ISPs tonight
so you're saying is that is the
traditional model of international
treaties the way to go to to get a
handle on security in in cyber security
in a borderless environment in a
bordello cyberspace right so the the
answer to that I think is no they're not
compatible that's why we emphasize and
that's why the State Department and so
on have emphasized the value of norms of
behavior that is treaties are very
complicated instruments they take a very
long time to negotiate they're very hard
to get approval for and there's an I
gotta say that from what I personal view
from what I see there's kind of an
allergy to treaties there's actually
historically always been in an analogy
to treaties that's why it takes a
two-thirds majority of the Senate to
approve a treaty rather than just a
simple majority and so I think that
that's a problem I actually have a
postdoc here right now working on the
question of the the non national
organizations that are not governments
that that work to promote cyber security
and stability of the Internet such as
the ISPs so the the role that the
various organizations within the
internet society play and so on there's
a there's a very robust but fragile
infrastructure underlying the stability
of the the net that we know all of them
are in some sense intellectual
descendants who jump Postel right and it
you know what he did at one point was
you know it had to be scaled up and of
course he's no longer with us but you
know what he did was to sort of run the
Internet he used the closest thing to an
Internet master that anybody ever saw
and now all these organizations have
sprung up the hype
nations don't understand that part
it's you know so as I say after the
postdoc working on how to promote an
understanding of that and getting rid of
the the getting rid of this notion I
mean my my aspiration goes to get rid of
the notion that governments are going to
take over that kind of function because
they can't do it in my view a chance to
look into the problem of agent arises a
problem of Aging IOT devices devices
which came all it expected that some key
devices some time last year the car
decades and actually you you recommend
removal policy each half yeah
so it's being practical through to 20
points devices embedded in some house
refrigerators used for 20 years yes yes
yes and the yes the the question of how
you update and and and refresh and and
so on is a big deal nobody knows how to
do stuff that bug free and nobody knew
can anticipate the features that people
are gonna want in the future and they
don't want to replace their whole
refrigerator in order to do it okay so
if you put a path into it then because
you don't want to be stuck with what's
old then you are what's new could be bad
as well as good and so that's I agree
that that's a that that's a constant
tension and that's one of the issues
that you have to you have to deal with I
know no disagreement with no
disagreement with me on that but no we
didn't we didn't get into that level of
detail we said this is an issue that has
to be addressed this the GS a big enough
player to significantly influence the
market and if the GSA said
alright the GSA is the General Services
Administration and they have they buy
stuff for the US government and the
question is aren't they big enough to
say I want something that's really
secure and to influence the the company
is to develop really secure version and
give it to the government and then they
can sell it to the commercial to the to
the commercial world turns out that the
idea of using government procurement
Authority does come up we that is a
recommendation in the report that we
want to use government procurement
authority to increase security and so on
there are those of us who look at the
checker in the past of such attempts and
sort of wonder whether or not that's
really a viable model so yeah it's
certainly worth trying whether or not it
will actually succeed given that all the
other attempts that have not succeeded
that were based on the same model not
clear yet other argument no we the
report does not does not address
attribution per se in that regard I
agreed that if you do a search on the
word attribution the report I don't know
I don't remember coming up so I think
that we we did not I actually have a
review paper right that's right up on
SSRN right now on that that really looks
at the attribution issue from soup to
nuts I mean from beginning to end which
addresses all the technical issues and
the the political issues and legal
issues and so on which you might want to
look at but no the Commission didn't do
that
alright I'm a liability question the
assumption that that will be I was
wondering whether or not it was
considered that you might not have
somebody some entity to go after and I
mean that in the sense that number one
the entity in question might be a
start-up that literally just has 50
dollars left in their bank account or
number two the entity in question might
be some random LLC face of a company
that's based in a different country and
all they have on the ground here is just
P o box okay so your your question is
what consideration was there in that
that's it that's at a level of detail
which we didn't address I think the
answer to that though is that we have
that problem now mm-hmm
with and we have a fairly robust
liability regime for for physical
products forget about the cyber part for
physical products and in practice what
you do is you go after the party with
the deepest pockets okay so if you don't
if you can't get the if you can't get
the guy who put in the defective wrong
chip because he's the security make me
kill because he's you know offshore or
whatever you go after the system
integrator if you can't get the city and
if checked in the system integrator then
then you go after the distributor and
you know and so on let me so and so it
goes you may say this is a stupid way to
run a country okay and then what the
lawyers will disagree with you what we
have right so there is a robust
liability structure robust structure for
enforcing liability I don't know if it's
robust enough because I'm thinking of
prior to the Obama administration he
found weaknesses in security for
infrastructure if the company is liable
then they pay for fixing but if the
cyber attack occurs and the taxpayer is
responsible that's true
and there there is actually legislate
there's actually a in the in the
executive order I believe that that
actually exempts some Fung from this
kind of liability you're absolutely
right and but that's true for cyber
security it's not true for any other
aspect of security or reliability and
our here's the argument okay
the argument is that if I have an IOT
device of a toaster okay and the toaster
burns my house down because some hacker
got into it okay I'm gonna sue the
manufacturer of the toaster okay and
he's not the manufacturer of the toaster
is not going to be able to bracket off
the IT part of it that says no no no we
can't accept liability for that part
that's what I mean no I mean we're gonna
I'm gonna sue the the and I don't care
what the EULA says okay there's going to
be some judge that's gonna come along
and say that's contrary to public policy
okay that's bad policy and I'm not gonna
allow that stand and at that point and
you know that will be appealed and so on
but if that's the way it'll start so I
think that's the way it's gonna go
and and the question there is do you
want to get in front of it with to
establish that some sort of coherent
regime or do you want to have random
judges deciding on what this is now
knowing the way the country works I
suspected that you know that the random
judges are the waiter but they're but
they're not but the point is that that
they they are eventually going to go
down to that direction it's really
implausible to think of any other
scenario connections between devices and
really difficult to define which device
is responsible to still balance your
house but totally wrong because some
control a new custom order provided and
change
what you're telling me is that the
establishing lot extent the
responsibility and the liability loss is
complicated and that's true but that's
complicated now and we sort it out
different and that the my refrigerator
might have rather you know dosed you but
I don't care that's that's not green
that's right it's a different it's a
different exactly and that's misaligned
incentives you know that if I buy a
refrigerator I don't care I'm not going
to invest in more security to make you
more secure that's right that's right
and that's an example of perverse
incentives people who are not you from
danger sir yes so if your refrigerator
attacks me I'm going to like why can't I
see you
I made brothersu large refrigerator
maker gentleman what the heck I don't
like I don't like your shiny yet well I
agree that there's I agree that there
are interesting ways of looking at this
and we'll see how it sorts itself out my
mail the only point here is that you
can't say with confidence that there's
never gonna be liability for
cybersecurity breaches it will be their
house I mean I mean some decisions which
would be good well I think was we'll see
the the the the whole tort liability
system at this point is established out
of common practice of common law okay
and that's likely how this is going to
go to sign what is a reasonable data
security standard they're going to be
the insurance companies we also talked
about
patient cause of the sighting whether
they're in the cause of your litigation
a lot the people are going to decide
whether to pay on that claim made
against you who are going to be the
insurance company's going to necessarily
be behind the times it's reasonable
state-of-the-art security standards
require no disagreement know that no
disagreement with that that happened in
fire security in fire safety and so on
and it'll happen in cyber security - and
geared towards economic considerations
was that yes yes yes the real insurance
companies is interested in the report
yes it is tell me why you believe that
it's cheaper to do cyber security from
the beginning I don't believe it
platform that doesn't assume that every
program that runs in the system has
access to everything as I test all my
files how does that how does that it's
unconventional but it's not easy it's
not harder actually you need to worry
for small companies to follow over some
standard world security because if out
there that main vent the good device but
that security and it would be very
difficult to change you if the device
comes the idea of putting constraints
explicit constraints it's like standards
like electricity you know I know the
problem is that nobody knows what to put
in that stand in that code of combat for
security over here oh I was going to say
that with with intelligent well-meaning
people disagree often it's a semantic
disagreement in the terminology are you
saying that designing insecurity from
the start is cheaper than having a
system release without security are you
saying that it's cheaper than releasing
it first and retrofitting it later if
you start on UNIX or Windows or Mac and
then try to add the security in
additionally adding that security will
cost you more of course but that's not
the issue yes most of the news reasoning
was that when you're first trying to get
something out of the door as cheaply as
possible is it cheaper to put out
something that's we ordered without
something doesn't get harder so fastest
question to speed no actually kept so
for example we learned good programming
practice is to encapsulate isolate
functions from each other if that's a
security concern as well if you do that
so it is done securely that's just as
easy as encapsulating for functionality
this is - it's not a hard no no no
nothing startups the way I know them
okay I just don't believe it I'm gonna
start instead I see Kluge's coming up
there all the time
okay the right way look I know the right
way to do all this there's a proof of
concept okay i gobbled to the other
something just as weird just to show
that it works okay then the right thing
to do at that point is to throw it away
and start over again and do it right
okay okay that means I agree with you
that's the right way to do it but that
costs extra and it will take more time
to get something out to the market then
if I just market the Cluj okay there's a
there's an old say but you know the
question is you will throw away your
first attempt right the question will
question is what are you going to throw
it away before after you deliver it to
the customer right that's the real
question
okay and in in the environment in which
time to market is everything the answer
is obvious you deliver the thing that
you're gonna throw away later and that's
my point that's why I don't believe the
comment the conventional programmer
which includes 99% of us in the world
will start out on a classic operating
system because he doesn't know right
that part right and if you start out
that way then your first one will be
insecure
so you don't start out that way and
that's unconventional and you shouldn't
you shouldn't start out that way if your
goal is to have a secure reliable system
at the end of it but that's not your
goal your goal is to get market share
examples where we have improved
usability and functionality because we
added security yes I believe that but I
believe that but there I would argue
that those are very much the exception
has to be when you talk to people they
say there's a fundamental conflict
between security and usability security
and functionality and if you start from
that premise you will find that to be
true what I'm saying is the examples
that show that you that that premise is
false every time we've tried to do it we
found a way to do it because we started
from the better promise ok well I think
these axes are in some sense security
and usability or some other desirable
attribute ok now my claim is that there
is and you can argue about whether or
not you know but there's a some curve at
some place that says that you have to
train off security against usability at
some point I understand but so that
means the curve moves and you changed
the unit's that's all but that's closer
than at some point is now I also fully
acknowledge that down here I can
certainly have both crappy usability and
crappy security there's bad that's easy
I know how to do that right and so under
those circumstances I clearly can't
improve both and there's no there's no
question about that but when you I'm
like and my claim is that when you get
into this borderline region that there
is gonna be a trade-off we have a quite
secure one of our tools is quite secure
we had a user actually ask us how to
turn on security so the use of
was there the security was there you
were closer to the upper right-hand
corner to the Levin to the lower left so
we have a we have an example that shows
it can be done I don't I don't disagree
with it I don't think it changes the the
the general statement there are general
patterns but conventional operating
systems do not support that on your
premise seem to be the thread least some
of the startups rushing something out
for at least some of the designers we're
more worried about going bankrupt than
they are about stuff that lies ten years
down the road yeah for some designers
that may or may not be scrupulous there
will always be some people who find that
it's easier or better or faster or more
pragmatic to get something out however
they have to do that and never get
around to filling in the gaps well that
I think that statement I think is
uncontroversial no I don't think so I
think these guys even these guys would
believe that but I think the question is
how generally true that is and how easy
it is to and whether that's sort of the
the default assumption that that that
characterizes most of the world yeah I
can slap something together but if I'm
writing an enterprise out Service
something like that that has to be in a
mission-critical environment I'm gonna
have to make that first version
reasonably good and what I'm saying is
if it is good design principles at that
point the security comes along pretty
much perfect pretty much the startup
you're talking about it a six-month
cycle to produce the first product
that's not what we're talking about
we're talking about the mission critical
Enterprise out the company goes out of
business that this thing doesn't do its
job for those things I believe that
using Gupta's
principles from the start get you out
the door faster and cheaper but with
existing frameworks like the NIST
framework in particular it won't give
you security but there are frameworks
that will give you as part of your basic
design as part of what you do anyway for
reliable code we'll give you this
occasion well having seen a bunch of
very large bet your company kinds of of
enterprise software development
operations tanked because they were
unable to get to get their act together
to do what you're saying I'm I certainly
don't disagree with the theoretical
possibility I just think that it's just
very very rare because if I was going
there I would start from here the best
practice today isn't even good in many
respects and trying to follow best
practices that will get you in that kind
of thing we're gonna turn off Neath the
cameras so Jones can cover
okay
you